the government shutdown continues longer
than any in history I'm told this is a
crisis government shutdown crisis
another Trump generated crisis in this
crisis Crisis crisis it's causing chaos
confusion pain it's just too much say
the Washington Post and New York Times
but wait a second
looking around America I have to ask
where's that crisis most everything
seems pretty normal
how is everything today life goes on
pundits speak as if government's the
most important part of America but it
isn't we need some government but most
of life the best of life goes on without
government much of an inspite of
government of course if you're one of
the 800,000 federal workers who aren't
being paid the shutdown is a big deal
are you freaking kidding me again
seriously the furloughed workers get a
lot of attention they're not getting
paid but they will get paid they always
do after shutdown don't get me wrong the
shutdown is a real problem columnist
Paul Krugman giggles about it being
Trump's big libertarian experiment but
it's not libertarian government's
endless rules are still in effect and
soon workers will be paid for not
working this is the most unliberated
experiment but there are lessons to be
learned under President Obama's shutdown
government officials wouldn't allow
people to enter public parks the
National Park Service is blocking access
to parks and monuments this shut down
the administration's allowing people in
parks so PBS finds a new crisis too much
garbage National Park surfaces can't
clean up the mess until Congress and the
president reach a spending deal but now
volunteers sometimes pick up the trash
private citizens will step in to do some
things government workers used to do
The Washington Post finds another
problem farmers aren't receiving
government support checks but why do
farmers even get support checks the
purpose of the subsidy was to protect
the food supply but most fruit and
vegetable farmers don't get subsidies
and they do fine there's no shortage of
tangerines pairs of broccoli grain
cotton and corn farmers could suck it up
and do fine too much of government we
could just get rid of the New York Times
says shut down curtails FDA Food
Inspection oh no
we'll be poisoned but if you read the
smaller print you'd learn that 80% of
food inspection is done by the
Agriculture Department and there are
still inspecting but more importantly
the main reason food is safe is not
government it's competition fear of
getting a bad reputation inspires most
food producers to employ more safety
inspectors than government requires beef
carcasses undergo hot steam rinses and
microbiological testing that go well
beyond what government demands yet
politicians want us to think it's all
about government where government work
is needed privatize much of it even
security work like what the TSA does is
done better by the private sector go to
San Francisco's Airport you'll notice
the lines are shorter and they move more
quickly and passengers say the screeners
are nicer not only are they nicer the
TSA acknowledged that they were better
at finding contraband that's because
their private contractors they have to
be better or they might get fired
government never fires itself we
shouldn't shut down the government over
a dispute and you want to shut it down
about the last time Chuck you shut it no
no no finally it's absurd that this
shutdown is supposedly about
appropriating 5.7 billion dollars for
part of a border wall that's less than
what Washington spends every day 54
billion dollar increase in the defense
budget well the Senate has passed
the farm bill a multibillion-dollar
legislative package our debt will soon
reach 22 trillion dollars government
squanders money on useless things they
spent $300,000 studying whether Japanese
quail are more sexually promiscuous on
cocaine
so when government workers protest and
say we are all essential I say give us a
break